тисяч залишилося 11 до бачив дартмут диск і
далося воно не вдалині теракт 3 саморобний
бомба здетонувала били автобус ці
паровози у роботі в дортмундській
борусії папірець поранений захисник
футбольному клубу марк бартру
як би ви books залишився на секунди
раніше ми вас серйозно постраждати і вся
команда яко їхала на матч із молоком
поліція за три мало підозрюваного
п'ятницю 25 не був спокушений стій ранку в
містечку ротенбург на нектарин api в ній
не матч він і не бійся 20 вісімковий
електротехнік з німецькою та російською
room агентством на ім'я Сергій
перетворені розголошуються середини
ісламіст і на футбольний біль вільник
основна версія слідства теракт швидких
нових моделей спроба вибуття кому кабель
проти борусії щоб за роботи призначено
не акції клубів на параду дніпре
дозрівання взяв кредит і
додаток звання опціоні сертифікати на
суму 78000 євро щоб у чутний момент
тигра ти на них на біржі адже ми sky жив
і вийняла член його через звучну
активність на ринку опціонів
тепер ми знаємо їжте вин куб ev3 про
креми деривативи на акції борусії
верхню допомогу та вітру б вставки на
падіння акцій на біржі та б'ючий сценах
тата рівен куб і 11 cry дня в день [ __ ]
рваний травня мамочкою привід же немає в дусі
в куб однак повз новачок перехоплення
рада право курантил
за інформацію видання bild аферист
проїв торговий апарат юзай підріз і в
готелі для rewe до розмістилася а перед
матчем дарт миска команда і давимо за
бронь його в номер в [ __ ] хові прилаштувати
підозрюваних активу вати дистанції
стоїш у готелі
противники ось еліс році чіп якщо ви
бухим почалася паніка на тому місці до
3-го най залишити шоу ресторан і зам.
васабі стейк провернула у вови і 1000
клієнт бубни за задоволений своїм номером
через ти ще ви 2-го століття він бубни на
вулицю та з центральним входом до готелю
ріжте народжений вся погода на кращий номер
на найвищому за версією спецоперації
взяв і участь сотні поліцейських випадок
шанують ще підозрюваний вже скаати
ісламістами не перебивав, а вихопивши
дезорієнтувати та права
intel винза маскова ви бухою п'ятірок
терористичного у група ваня
ісламська держава
д підозрювали disto ви в хілку поки не
відразу милана думка засоби спальники
у нього не було ми викликаємо ви на vaccine
і в замах у нас швидкість явному ви
готові в нього глухого купер і струмінь і
нанесення на безтурботних тілесних вушок
джим футбольних біль у льні
і нове питання від риму не підозрювала з
підвищенням для команди добрий то рахунки
першим може красиво протити 1000
трапилося та поставити на тему краб наук
буде скинутий викликати заломах в
боці відра за
курка раді гарний народжувати на біс
пеку ж тебе людей такі каламут і ви
абсолютно не чоловік або одночасно мід і глава
мвф
землі первинний рейн-вестфалія ральф ігор
назвавши за 3 травня хороший новий але і для
футболу гривні борусії
недавно єдину футбольного клубу в не
менше не з акціями на біржі заявив ще
заходи в стеку та стоп але посилати